The Colosseums Big Brother, The Circus Maximus
The Colosseum is one of the most iconic landmarks
in Rome and incredibly popular with tourists.
Movies would have you think that chariot races,
gladiator shows, and battle simulations always
took place there, but that isn’t true.
The Colosseum was finished relatively recently
in 80 AD.
Before its completion, a more popular venue
for such things was the much more massive
Circus Maximus.
The Circus Maximus was arguably the largest
structure in ancient Rome, with the capacity
to seat 250,000 people according to Pliny
(roughly a quarter of Rome’s population
at the time; some historians today think the
number might have been a tad smaller than
Pliny said, around 150,000 rather than 250,000.
But either way, it was really, really big.)
It was built around the 6th century B.C.—well
before the Colosseum was even a thought.
The fifth king of Rome, Tarquinius Priscus,
created the track which would later be used
for chariot races, positioning it between
the Palatine and Aventine Hills.
Historically, the area is known as the possible
location of the famous Rape of the Sabine
Women.
If you’re unfamiliar, it’s a Roman legend
that Romulus, the founder of Rome, negotiated
with the Sabines who lived in the area to
let him and his followers (who were mostly
male) marry their women.
When they refused, Romulus hosted chariot
races which distracted the men and allowed
the Romans to kidnap the Sabine women.
The Roman historian Livy assures us that no
sexual assault took place; rather, Romulus
reasoned with the women and offered them citizenship
and the ability to give birth to free men
if they married the Roman men.
Whether true or not, what better place to
set up the race track for subsequent chariot
races?
The main purpose of the Circus Maximus was
indeed to hold chariot races as well as provide
a venue for the Ludi Romani, or “Roman Games”.
The games were often sponsored by rich, powerful
Romans, and were used to honour the gods.
Ludi could be full-day or half-day events
and included all manner of entertainment.
From chariot racing, gladiatorial displays,
plays, parades, religious ceremonies, and
feasts, there was something for everyone at
the Circus Maximus.
The space was also used to celebrate triumphs,
or successes on the battle field.
For instance, Tarquin the Proud celebrated
his triumph there as a sort of homage to the
god Jupiter for his victory over the Pometia.
The Circus underwent numerous improvements
over the many centuries it was in use.
The first Etruscan king created a raised wooden
platform to seat Rome’s rich and famous,
while his grandson added additional seating
for the commoners.
Around 50 BC, Caesar ordered that the seating
be extended around the track, which resulted
in the largest seating capacity the Circus
Maximus had yet seen.
However, it proved to be prone to damages.
In 31 BC, a fire swept through the stadium,
destroying many of the seats that Caesar had
so recently built.
It was rebuilt, but another fire during Emperor
Nero’s time saw further destruction.
In addition, the area was notorious for flooding
as a stream had to be redirected to provide
enough room for the Circus’ construction.
It was rebuilt out of stone around the end
of the first century AD, likely to avoid further
fire and water damage.
Initially, the Ludi were held annually or
a couple of times each year.
However, Rome was constantly expanding.
Soon, Ludi became something of a status symbol
for those hosting them.
The need to impress combined with the popularity
of the shows and games resulted in more and
more games being held.
By the second century BC, the number of games
had grown considerably—around 57 days were
dedicated to Ludi, or over one every week!
The Emperors of Rome were pressured to build
specialized venues to host a variety of different
events at once.
So at this point while the Circus remained
a popular place to host chariot races, many
of the other games moved location.
This brings us to the Colosseum, originally
called the Flavian Amphitheatre, with construction
beginning around 72 AD, under the reign of
Emperor Vespasian.
The Colosseum was well-designed; in the shape
of an ellipse, allowing for seating all around
as well as for sound from the ground level
to be relatively easily heard throughout the
amphitheater.
It also had significantly smaller capacity
than the Circus Maximus, able to seat only
around 55,000 viewers.
Nevertheless, the Colosseum replaced the Circus
as the prime space for gladiatorial shows
and staged animal hunts, called venatio.
There are even reports that simulated sea
battles took place there at one time, but
it’s unclear today how exactly that worked.
Needless to say, the games remained extremely
popular throughout the years.
The Colosseum was actually kept in use until
the 1300s, when an earthquake left part of
it in shambles.
The stone that fell was used on other buildings,
and a religious order moved in.
The Church continued to have a hold on the
Colosseum well into the 1800s.
The Circus Maximus didn’t fall out of use
until the 6th century AD, having been used
for over one thousand years at that point.
The stones in the structure were also gradually
taken away to use on other buildings, while
the actual chariot track was buried under
water and soil.
It was excavated starting in the 19th century.
Today, the Circus is a park used for gatherings,
concerts, and celebrations—a modern twist
on an ancient venue.
The Colosseum is, of course, a popular tourist
attraction, with millions of people visiting
every year.
It’s also been used as a venue for Roman
Catholic religious ceremonies in recent years,
though large spectacles are no longer an option
due to the fragile state of the monument and
the minimal seating that survives.
Bonus Facts:
• Building such huge monuments takes a lot
of money.
The Colosseum was largely funded by money
taken from the Jewish Temple at the Siege
of Jerusalem.
• The site of the Colosseum was actually
heavily populated originally.
However, when the famous 64 AD fire spread
through the city (started, some people believe,
at the Circus Maximus), Emperor Nero snatched
up the ruined land and built the Domus Aurea,
his grandiose palace, on top of the charred
land.
However, his palace was later torn down.
• The chariots that raced at the Circus
Maximus were color-coded, and could be pulled
by teams that consisted of between 4 and 12
horses.
The horses that won became famous throughout
Rome.
The charioteers also saw a lot of fame—and
riches.
The most famous charioteer of his time was
Scorpus, who reportedly won a whopping 2000
races.